happy belated birthday and what better
way to celebrate with like the number
one show all over the world
crazy crazy I could not be more thankful
because I did not I knew it was gonna do
well with that well I mean I don't you
don't want to set yourself up for
disappointment so it was just like when
it came I was like okay wow it's just
happening it was like one of those
things I sat down and I was like I'll
check out this show and then cut to I
finished the whole thing in one sitting
and I'm like in a puddle of tears it's
just some of the freshest best comedy
I've seen in a long time and then it
just like gut punches you in the end
it's such a great show thank you so much
yeah I don't think a lot of people were
expecting that from Mindy you know
coming from the office and things like
that but it is it's not just laughter it
touches on some real life stuff and I'm
really happy how they accomplished that
now is it strange having this like
sudden just like uptick in in fans from
quarantine like you haven't really been
able to like go out right and have
people just like coming up to you and
saying stuff or if they do you're like
sixty please yeah you know it's um I
think maybe it worked out well because I
did not obviously expect I knew the show
was gonna be you know a hit and do well
but I didn't expect my character to get
so much attention and so that happening
like social media following has been
through the roof and all that is you
know it's really really cool but um I
don't I'm it's almost better maybe it'd
happen that way because it's it's a
smoother adjustment to it whereas I did
actually go for a run the other day and
I got recognized and I'm show not used
to that and they were like I heard them
like saying that's him that's him and I
was like there's no way to talking about
me right now and turn around they're
both pointing it because like you know
I'm ready for it I'm thankful but if
like you know it's probably better this
is like an easier transition into that
you know happening so are you from LA
originally yeah I grew up here until I
was 12 and then lived in Orlando Florida
for a while Miami and then up and up in
Northeast Georgia in the middle of
nowhere and then Atlanta and then back
home Wow so to kind of grow up here and
then
take that drive down iconic Sunset
Boulevard and see your face like what is
that what did that feel like so I used
to live on Sunset Boulevard at the time
with my sister and brother-in-law and I
worked at soul cycle at the near the
center the Sunset Plaza was Hollywood in
there yeah and I would have you know I'd
walk to work every day to avoid you know
like paying a parking fee there's two
dollar parking fee you know like I don't
want to pay it so I'm gonna save money I
walked a mile every day and I'd be
walking past all the billboards and ads
shows and just be like you know I I
wanted it so bad like I can't explain
how much I dreamed of like seeing my
face on a billboard or even not my face
but just a show I was a part of and see
it posted up you know so then I was
walking past that apartment or driving
past an apartment and saw the billboard
right in front of it and it was the most
surreal moment ever because that was
four years ago I was where I would have
said like it's impossible you know so it
was really cool what advice would you
give to people who are kind of feeling
maybe how you were feeling a few years
back realize I mean you got to realize
that this takes time and you have to I
think you really have to evaluate if
you're if it's worth your time you know
and that means I think doing it for the
right reason I I came to the point where
I realized there was nothing I was
nothing else I was gonna be happy doing
so I was willing to do this and struggle
and potentially never make it until the
day I died
you know it's like that's how bad I want
it but also just you know realize you're
enough and don't let don't let this town
change you you know a lot of times
you're pulled in every direction make
you feel like you got to look like this
guy or act like that guy just this guy
or girl whatever and um you can lose
yourself doing that and then the pursuit
isn't worth it
at that point I think so yeah there's
definitely like a lot of people that
tell you to like change yourself in
certain ways and you have to kind of
stick to stick to your guns a little bit
you know yeah and that's that I think
that makes you stand out and makes you
you and makes you more you know hireable
in my eyes this show is so special
because you know I've seen I I mean I've
seen my culture on TV thousand different
ways a million differ
times and then to see this Indian
American family at the core of this show
I mean what does that mean to you to be
a part of a project like that I love
that this show is so diverse and it
touches on so many real-life topics but
and I've said this before is just I what
I love is that it's not preachy about it
and it's not so on the nose about it and
because there's a lot of shows that I
watched and it's just like you can tell
that the whole message of the show is
like I'm a minority and this is my
struggle and this is why life is hard
and that's what the entire story is
gonna be about where it's the point
where just like it's like a violinist
playing you know and it's like I get it
but like this show what I love about it
is that it's just merely a fact about
each character you know what's Devi
being Indian is not her identity it's
not her definition it's just a fact
about her and it touches on how she
struggles with that identity not being
Indian enough or being too Indian or
whatever but there's so many other
things going on that it doesn't ever
just pinpoint focus on that type of
stuff so I'm honored because I think it
yeah I think it's more of a real-life
depiction on the characters like that
you know like no character goes do life
is like oh I'm like minority in my whole
life story you know so it's more real to
me I was reading that your character
actually changed a little bit after you
were cast can you talk a little bit
about how Paxton evolved once you got
the role yeah that was really cool
actually I was in wardrobe fitting with
Salvador Perez and our ad yuko was there
and I knew by her name is huge Japanese
so I started conversing with her in
Japanese my mom is Japanese grandmother
spoke Japanese to me and I took it in
school for two years so I love to
practice it anytime I can and I guess
Sal told Lang and Mindy I was doing that
and Lane came up to me and was like hey
are you speaking to Japanese with Yuko
and at first I thought I was like in
trouble because we went to like
sensitivity training with Universal and
they were like don't mimic people don't
do this don't do that I was like yeah
but like she was like oh do you mind if
we make your character part Japanese and
I was like yeah so the next thing I knew
there was a hyphenated yoshito at the
end of the name that's awesome how do
you feel like you are the most
like Paxton and how do you feel like
you're the least like Paxton I think I'm
the most like Paxton in a sense that um
I I can relate to being a book judged by
your cover and also having you know
before people know you having you know
them jab at your intelligence I can't
relate to Paxton in a sense that mm I
was not I didn't have an extreme apathy
toward school I was a straight-a student
I was in like all college classes I was
you know my and I never went to one
party I never drinks of alcohol and
nothing like that
a very very strict mother in a great way
I love it because if she pushed me so
hard but I can also relate you know
Paxton just um a book judge by his cover
but also having a real heart of gold
underneath and I mean the guy was I was
always trying to stand up for the little
guy and you know really I made friends
everyone possible and but yeah he's uh
there were a lot of people that were
like oh not not that they would call me
stupid but when I would you know it
would see like me you know do something
intellectual they'd be like oh you're
actually smart
Wow okay thank you for the backhanded
compliment so can't be hot and smart you
know science doesn't work that way
the tick-tocks of people trying to
recreate your shirtless scene are pretty
great
[Music]
how did he do that that's like a moment
for me when I saw people like I saw how
many people are doing it I had no idea
that that move was gonna be such a good
thing and kudos to Mindy in them like
they told me um they originally wanted
me to go like their like practice doing
it they wanted me to take it off from
behind with one hand and I kept choking
myself so I was like it's not gonna work
this way then I'm just gonna you know
it's going around my neck so we ended up
having INR only how about this way and
they did it with you know the other arm
so I was like there would ya just do as
fast as you can
so I went home and I was like it became
like muscle memory so it was a good time
yeah did you have to practice or is this
like a skill you already had I still
find myself taking my shirt off like
that believe it or not sometimes when I
get home like just I don't know I did it
so many times
I get home completely alone I'm about to
get a shower I'm like like wow you got
it yes what are your hopes for for
season two we kind of see Paxton have a
big moment of growth at the end so what
are you hoping for season two which is
definitely happening I assume you know
no one to the fat lady sings right but
it looks good um I would really so I
would enjoy you know I know how you know
Ben has an episode diving over the into
his individual life and explaining his
character I think that would be
interesting with Paxton seeing his home
life is dynamic more so with his sister
his his parents and then I also think
would be cool like to have somewhat of a
role reversal with Devi and Paxton and
what I mean by that is the whole first
season my Davy's chase backs he's a
bleep or so she thinks
and then now he's on her doorstep pining
for her heart at the end of season one
well I don't spoiler alert
but you know it's I would love for the
season two like maybe he's too late and
this is the first time in his life he's
ever been told no or or
you know felt like it it wasn't easy for
him to acquire someone's heart and make
them like him you know so to see like
kind of an insecure part of pack seemed
like maybe he's too late I don't know
what I should do you know and and that
dynamic really interesting
[Music]